it was the same soviet story of
shrouding their space research in
secrecy
in 1966
the soviet union's luna 9 probe
cushioned by airbags successfully landed
on the moon and returned the first
pictures from the surface
ever since governments have dominated
the design and delivery of lunar landers
with the united states
china
israel and india all making attempts
now the action is shifting from
governments to a number of commercial
outfits that are trying to make lunar
exploration happen on fast schedules and
lean budgets
next year one company's lander is set to
touch down on the moon where it will
hunt for a critical and scarce resource
water
astrobotic a startup based in an
unassuming pittsburgh warehouse has
received a slice of nasa's 2.6 billion
dollar program intended to galvanize the
private sector's development of lunar
landers and rovers
commercial lunar payload services or
clips is supporting astrobotic and
similar companies with the goal of
sending landers to the moon twice a year
along with a bevy of scientific
instruments
first up for astrobotic is peregrine a
treehouse sized lander expected to
launch from cape canaveral florida next
year aboard a vulcan rocket
it will chart a course for lacus mortis
a smooth plane of lava near the moon's
equator the capabilities of the 21
instrument payloads aboard peregrine
will be somewhat limited since the
lander will be stuck in one spot but it
will provide a baseline for how landers
contaminate the surface with their own
gases which confounds the hunt for water
as well as show how its payload of
instruments work together
in 2023 astrobotic plans to launch a
larger lander griffin which will ferry
the nasa engineered viper rover to the
moon
its instruments should determine not
only the trace abundances of water but
also its origin how much of the water
comes from solar wind versus asteroids
or comet collisions
astrobotic isn't the only private
company working under the auspices of
nasa's clips program houston-based
intuitive machines will launch its nova
sea around the same time as peregrine
and another lander built by maston space
systems in california is set to launch
in 2023
if all goes well the lander program will
deliver a steady supply of experiments
across wide-ranging fields of science
researchers are planning an instrument
to probe the moon's interior
and another to snap the first ever
picture of earth's magnetic field from
outside the planet
even astronomers will hitch a ride as a
radio telescope is placed on the moon's
far side
where it can scan the cosmos amid a
quiet unknown on earth
[Music]
you